there was this old Saturday Night Live
sketch called daily affirmation with
Stuart Smalley who was played by Al
Franken who is now a politician and he
would look into the mirror and say I'm
good enough I'm smart enough and doggone
it people like me and by the end of it
he would be saying to himself I am in a
shame spiral I'm going to die homeless
and penniless and overweight no one will
ever love me I am a fraud I'm a phony
right and so what was funny about that
was that we all know that that doesn't
work when you feel acutely anxious and
self-doubting the last thing you should
do is lie to yourself right so what
happens is that that creates a kind of
backlash that makes you feel not only
more anxious but now you're also a liar
right now you're lying to yourself so
that's not the kind of self affirmation
that I'm talking about the kind of self
affirmation I'm talking about is this
where you really do identify what are
your core values what are the things
that no one can really change about you
why do they matter to you and you you
kind of anchor yourself in them now what
the research shows and there literally
are hundreds of studies on self
affirmation and most of this was work
done by Stanford psychologists led by
Claude Steele and what they find is that
when people self affirm it is the
simplest exercise it really is one what
are your core values - why do they
matter to you three write about a time
when you express this when people do
that it dramatically lowers their stress
and anxiety self-reported stress and
anxiety it lowers their their
neuroendocrine measures of stress and
anxiety like cortisol and epinephrine
and it allows them to perform much
better in a stressful task so somebody
made self affirmed and write about why
you know family matters to them and then
they go take a really hard math test not
only are they less stressed out they
actually do better on the math test now
what's funny about it is it's not
somebody saying to him or herself I'm a
math genius you know I'm a real Einstein
it has nothing to do with math the self
affirmation can have nothing to do with
math why does it work
it works because when we are reminded of
who we really are it's okay to not be
perfect right so you can go into that
stressful situation and know that no
matter what happens you are leaving it
as yourself so it's I think it's a
pretty pretty wonderful little
intervention there's a recent study
showing that employees whose
orientations focused on self affirmation
in both Indian and American call centers
those employees who did that orientation
as opposed to a general orientation
stated the job longer were happier and
provided better customer service for a
long time it's not something that lasts
only a day so it's pretty amazing okay
so you self affirmed now you know who
you are the next part is really how do
you access that in your sort of day to
day life when you're not facing one of
these big challenges you're naturally
expressing who you really are
because you're not afraid to tell your
friends what you care about or show your
family who you really are when you get
into those stressful situations the last
thing you're thinking about is I need to
make sure that I show them exactly who I
am and so instead showing them who you
are becomes very threatening and you
know that wall goes up and now you can't
access those things even if you want to
you can't access them because you're in
kind of fight-or-flight mode so the it
all turns on feeling powerful and what I
mean by power is not power over others
that's social power personal power is
power over the self so its power to
access the resources that you already
possess right so so it's the things that
you internally possess that your again
your values your skills your knowledge
your personality when you feel powerful
you can access those things when you
feel personally powerless suddenly you
can't access those things so the
different the really important
difference between social power and
personal power
is that social power is zero-sum and
personal power is infinite everyone can
be personally powerful in fact I would
argue that you want people to be
personally powerful because you're
getting the best version of everyone
when they feel that way
personal power does not make people
competitive in this sort of zero-sum
fixed pie way it makes people open and
action-oriented and creative and you
know frankly just kind of more
interesting people